All right, give me a name.
>> Fredrick.
>> Fredrick, okay.
And a verb?
>> Fly.
>> Fly, all right.
Plural noun.
>> Plural noun, camels.
>> Camels, that's a good one.
Occupation?
>> Occupation?
Yoga instructor.
>> Fair enough.
And a place?
Let's go with Disney Land.
>> All right, we've got our Mad Lib.
Do you want to go ahead and read it?
>> Sure.
Hi, my name is Frederick and
I really like to fly camels.
I'm also a yoga instructor
at Disney Land.
>> Well your name isn't Frederick,
your name is Sean.
And you will be seeing
a lot of Sean in stage two.
Sean, would you like to introduce
yourself and this project?
>> Sure, hi there.
My name is Sean Lubbers and I spent my
summer working as an intern at Udacity
to help improve this nanodegree.
You'll learn a lot of
programming fundamentals and
you'll apply what you learned in the
work sessions by building a couple of
versions of a Mad Libs generator,
with the final product looking like
the one you saw Andy and I just play.
>> Now, if you're not super excited
about learning how to build a Mad Libs
game, don't worry,
that's not really the point.
This is just a simple way to capture
a lot of the most important ideas
in programming.